so we know we need to create layouts and
assets optimized for different screen
pixel densities and sizes so now is a
great time to introduce you to the
Android resource framework all
externalized
Android resources everything from
strings to layouts to draw Robles and
animations are all stored within your
project's res folder you've already been
putting your strings in the strings.xml
file stored in the values folder and
you've been putting your layouts into
the layout folder and you know to
reference your resources using @
notation with in both your XML all
within the code and then at runtime
Android will insert the appropriate
resource for you so far so good and
here's where things get a little more
interesting Android allows you to create
alternative versions of every resource
by placing them into folders with
different qualifiers we separate each of
those using a hyphen and we can add
those qualifiers based on anything from
language and/or dialect to whether the
device is docked the type of touchscreen
the pixel density of the display the
orientation of the screen and most
importantly for a responsive design in
particular the smallest available screen
with which you can support with that
layout at runtime Android will check the
current device configuration its
language its screen size pixel density
everything and then load the right
layout strings and drawables accordingly
and you can even chain these qualifiers
together for example to create a
different layout for German language
users to account for all of those really
long German words or more typically for
a combination of screen size and device
configuration now keep in mind that many
of these values can change at runtime
the most common change being that of
orientation and it's for this reason
that Android activities are destroyed
and recreated whenever the device
configuration changes and that's because
the layout and all of the resources
within it could be completely different
based on something as simple as a screen
orientation change now it's good
practice as well to localize your apps
and provide translated strings for all
of your users using this mechanism and
that's a task made a lot easier thanks
to Google Play publisher site they can
offer you this service it's also a
really good idea to
by different drawables at the
appropriate pixel density so you can get
a nice crisp image on every device and
when it comes to providing alternative
layouts Android has gone through a few
alternative models starting in the early
days with this screen buckets idea of
small normal large and extra-large but
since Android 3.2 the new smallest width
qualifier has given us much more
fine-grained control over our layouts